I'll be talking today about gussian
splatting but first as usual I'm going
to start off with a video which is going
to be 2 minutes and we'll go over all
the technical details really fast giian
splatting what's that it's a way to
render stuff really high fidelity really
fast it's a big deal because it's
totally different from any existing
Graphics Pipeline and is capable of
rendering scenes that look like this at
144 FPS the original research paper is
3D Gyan splatting for realtime Radiance
field rendering what does that mean I'll
explain how it works step one take a
bunch of pictures of stuff from
different angles then use an old
algorithm called structure for motion to
estimate a point cloud from the pictures
at different angles step two take every
point in the point cloud and say you're
a gussian now I'm a what a distribution
that looks like this but in 3D and also
can be skewed which is what I like to
call multivar everyone calls it that we
also assign a color and an alpha now we
can put all these Gans into one giant
Matrix with 16 columns and rows one for
every Gan this is all the data we need
to represent the scene so are we done no
step three rization meaning turn all
these gaussians into an image how the
simplified version is according to your
camera perspective project the Gans into
2D then sort them by depth then for
every pixel iterate over every Gan front
to back calculate their contribution to
that pixel then blend them all together
now we have an image so are we done no
part four training these gaans don't
have the right values so we need to
train them meaning adjust the values of
the gaussians so that they produce
images that look like the original
images this is a lot like training a
neural network but with zero layers
which is why it's so fast the training
also uses automated densification and
pruning meaning when a gussian is
struggling to fit a detail part of the
scene it splits into two gaussians and
when a gaussian alpha gets too low it
gets removed now we have a train set of
millions of gaussians that can be
rasterized from any angle to produce an
image okay now what well this is
extremely new it's kind of like when
traditional rasterization was first
invented and then Doom came along and
added shadows and everyone was like wow
you added shadows and then came
Reflections normal Maps indirect
lighting you know the graphics Pipeline
and this paper is basically Reinventing
step one now you may be thinking isn't
this the same as photogrametry no
because this is a rization technique
meaning it converts the underlying data
directly into an image without the need
for Ray tracing path tracing or
diffusion so why didn't exist till no
because even though it's a simple
operation for it to look as good as it
does you need millions of gaussians
which requires several gigs of vram so
is Graphics about to totally change
forever or is this a niche application
like photogrametry let me know what you
think and if you want to keep up with
this more researchy stuff follow me on
Twitter thank you for watching any
questions on uh the technical aspect of
Gan splatting cuz the rest of this is
going to be more about the broader
context I have zero idea about uh the
architecture and you're saying it's like
a narrow network with zero layers so
like I want to ask how does it look like
or like what's the operations so they're
just using gradient descent directly on
the representation of the scene okay
thanks since uh the implementation of
gaussian splatting there's been a lot of
community research work which includes a
lot of viewer implementations kind of
the first thing the community started
doing these listed on the left but
they're not very userfriendly
they usually have a very low frame rate
and the reason for that is there is a
sorting bottleneck so in gaussian
splatting every frame you need to sort
millions of gaussians which is very
expensive the original paper solves this
with parallel GPU radex sort which is
very straight forward with Cuda but not
so much on other platforms like on web
it can be hundreds of times slower but
there is one project that figured it out
which is Unity Gan splatting I didn't
pay much attention to this at first
because the readme says like oh this is
just code that's a mess that's been
thrown together over the weekend it's
garbage but it's actually by far the
best one and it uses AMD parallel radex
sword which is four times slower than
Cuda radex sword but the author of this
repository made a bunch of optimizations
that make it work pretty well anyway and
with this there's been some very cool
demos here is lining in gussian
splatting and then this one is
explosions in Gan splatting but this is
very technical lowlevel graph graic
programmer people it's not really
practically applicable yet to a broader
audience and that's what I'm most
interested in and for that another
solution to the Sorting problem is CPU
counting sort which is way slower than
GPU Ric sort but if you do it
asynchronously and you combine it with
other optimizations from that Unity
repository and also use web assembly to
make it faster it ends up being pretty
usable which is what I used in
implementing my own Library gplat doj s
this combines the unity optimizations
with web assembly CPU counting sort
here's how it looks I can pick something
like this
one and you can see it runs really fast
in the web this Library ended up being
pretty popular and I'm planning to add
some more features but the main priority
is that it can enable machine learning
demos for that I recently made a custom
gradio component this was actually
pretty easy since the gradio 3D model
viewer uses a library called babylonjs I
based my library syntax on babylonjs so
I could mostly just copy the uh gradio
component and just replace Babylon with
gplat and it works pretty well and
that's this one so it's just showing a
gradio component that implements the
viewer and then using this component I
made another demo called dream Gan mini
which is a miniature version of an
existing research project called dream
Gan choose any image you want and you
can generate the Gan splatting results
so
what's next well everything because
there's been a ton going on in the world
of calcium splatting it's all completely
new it's basically Reinventing the wheel
in a way that may be considered more AI
compatible so you can imagine there's a
ton that needs to be done like
compression animation generative
modeling language grounding but let's
not forget about meshes traditional 3D
this has nothing to do with gussian
splatting but it's very important in the
broader context the reason why gum
splatting is interesting as opposed to
meshes is that there's been a lot of
research going on in traditional 3D and
meshes but the actual step of
constructing the meshes from images or
volumetric representation has been the
same since 1987 it's been the
state-of-the-art is still marching cubes
which produces pretty much unusable
meshes unless you're a very skilled 3D
artist that can clean up the meshes and
then even then they could probably make
something better on their own and Gan
splatting on the other hand is easy for
AI to generate but on the other there's
a lot of research that's been coming out
very very recently like a week ago that
promises they figured out meshes so but
the code is an out so we'll see it's a
long story short 3D is very exciting
everything is in flux and nobody knows
where everything will actually settle in
the meantime we have a huge opportunity
to be at the center of all this research
for both gussian splatting and
traditional 3D so um stay tuned